this is so simple
oh I'm uncomfortable officer what's that
yes I would love to UM it was probably
one of the most beautiful experiences
I've ever had coupled because I was
living in the most beautiful place
Richmond and I was able to sort of leave
that heaven and go to a soundstage a
black soundstage four for four months
working with the nicest group of people
the kindest and most patient group of
people I've ever worked with when they
all had a tremendous amount riding on
them because new technology unknown
waters they didn't know if I could do
what they needed I didn't know if they
could give me what I knew it was just it
should have been a very stressful
situation but every single day was so
supportive and kind so I had probably
one of the best filming experiences I've
ever had when I did the film
I was very familiar with
Alfonso's work I had I had watched him
for so many years and longed to work
with him I I honestly never thought the
million years that I would be able to
work with him there was always a joke in
our office every time had a project I
was like do you think we should send it
to Alfonso Cuaron when we knew very well
that he only did his own material and
then I trusted him 100% because you had
the body of his work as proof we didn't
know what we were making really and and
it was unknown territory but we kept
going back to look at the work that he's
done so far thematically visually
emotionally and it wasn't supposed to be
a big blockbuster film is sort of a
avant-garde esoteric existential film
about loss and adversity in space and so
being on that journey with someone that
you knew you could trust a thousand
percent is what made it so so easy to go
on the into the day not having any idea
if it was gonna work how you were
physically gonna hold up how you were
mostly gonna hold up but you knew you
had Alfonso there so you knew you were
in a great place whether the film worked
or not didn't I don't think it crossed
anyone's mind it didn't cross mine but I
trusted him explicitly goes beyond being
a movie I felt it was an experience I
held my breath the entire time was the
I see it was a little looking everything
up on the water how do you experience
that same thing normally we don't I
think because you've seen so much of it
by the time you see the film but George
and I saw nothing we saw at we saw a
black box with wires and camera
equipment the matically we knew how
emotional the story was on this on the
on the page we just didn't know what it
was going to look like so we didn't have
that experience till we saw the whole
thing together in Venice with the music
with all the wires removed with all the
the the ambience and all the subtleties
and all the layering like you see the
movie for the third time and you see
something in the background that you
didn't see and and he meant for that
experience to be exactly that an
emotional and a very visceral experience
for the movie goer he wanted it to be so
at one point in the film he turned the
perspective of the camera so that you
could step on board and I think everyone
who had the reaction in the film was
having it because of something very
personal in their own lives and and
that's exactly what he wanted he didn't
want to placate the audience he wanted
to give them sort of what you get when
you read a book you bring your own
emotion your own visuals your own
imagination to it and I think that was
incredibly brave on his part but he so
trusted the viewer to be able to do that
it was just his job to figure out
visually how to make that moment so
everyone could sort of step aboard so
it's that's the way you were supposed to
feel and that's exactly what he was
going for thank you